دمار كبير خلفته القوات الاسرائيليه في
منزل عائله عويضات وسط مخيم عقبه جبر
للاجئين الفلسطينيين
المنزل الذي قصف بقذائف وجرفت غرفه واعتقل
اصحابه لم يكن احدا من المطاردين
الذين تبحث عنهم اسرائيل والذين تتهمهم
بمحاوله تنفيذ عمليه ضد مطعم اسرائيلي
قريب من اريحا قبل نحو اسبوع دخلوا ويبدو
مش معنيين في بيت معين كانوا معنيين في
المخيم كله
وبلشوا من اول مخيم بالعمل الرديء تبعهم
العمل الهزيل تبعهم وطلعوا انسحبوا وكانت
قواته اسرائيليه كبيره ترافقها جرافات قد
اقتحمت المخيم وسط اطلاق نار واصوات
انفجارات ما اوقعت 13 جريحا بين
الفلسطينيين اضافه لاعتقال اخرين
وتاتي العمليه العسكريه الواسعه هذه بعد
نحو تسعه ايام من الاقتحام الدموي لمخيم
الجنين وردود الفعل الدوليه والضغوط على
اسرائيل لوقف مثل هذه العمليات التي من
شانها تفجير دوامه عنف لا يحمد عقباها
يذكر ان فريقا امريكيا امنيا وسياسيا ظل
في المنطقه لمراقبه التزام الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بالتهدئه ومحاوله
اعاده الامور الى مسار هادئ يؤسس لعوده
المفاوضات او على الاقل يمنع الانهيار
الشامل عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه